hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to job simulator we're
gonna go with the door clerk I don't
know how to do that but wave used to
work at a UDF in Cincinnati and if you
don't know what a UDF is a busy legged
dairy store hello oh why do I want them
hello accurate simulation of convenience
store Clemmie okay
take a look at this board for
instructions and grab a ticket when
you're ready to get started
god damnit why is everything on the
ticket based system you know people
could just walk up and ask me and then I
would like begrudgingly help them I'm
the only thing related to this that I
did was working
Kroger's in the non-food stocking
section I was a non-food stocking clerk
and that basically meant I just stood at
the jewelry and perfume counter and
stock the adult diapers that's what I
did boobity boobity boo Bingbing okay
hello there's no one here though oh sure
you can still down here I don't know if
I'm supposed to do this yeah these seem
like important things okay I'll probably
the trash now that would have been yeah
that would have been smart to turn over
security camera boink
okay wait where am I Oh God I'm not real
I'm free oh my life is alive let's get
to business here's your first customer
hello don't steal anything I'm watching
you
everyone's a criminal until proven
otherwise oh wow I found an exploit okay
yay it's all the joy of doing this here
you go here you go that'll be you also
get one of those neat cylinders please
oh okay all right here we go
Oh God oh there you go
I don't want to heat it whoop
her mind then she was pissed about that
blowing okay there we go keep these on
the rollers there if I know anything
about convenience stores because I use
feed a lot of this type of food back in
Cincinnati when I was unbelievably poor
thank you acceptable I don't know how
this is gonna work madam but I'm gonna
just put faith in the system
Bubba oh wow you can be human thanks a
bunch
you're welcome I'll take money now pull
the lever on the register Kurt Runkles
oh you have oh okay we're doing it we're
training there you go hey profit okay
did I do good boss I do good I don't
know what I'm doing for stores like this
tomato your constant stream of customers
so the cashiers wouldn't have time to
contemplate the rapidly approaching
obsolescence okay that that's a little
unnecessary point blink
uh-huh give me money
no [ __ ] you
okay frozen slushy delights I like to
mix and match I don't know about you
guys at home but it's mine
how do i jumbo-sized this how do I do
that here you go boy have a good day
oh I can Maxima Oh oh my god okay I'm
gonna need to get you some more because
yes blue thermal paste pink I actually
imagined that I would enjoy battery acid
blue because I love all types of blue
you got anybody okay
keep the change [ __ ] off I don't need
your charity
well yesterday's news okay well then if
you want yesterday's news we've got a
lot of that no and read it then no one
reads it now hey well I've got just the
thing for you oh if I could only get it
is this made by the same people that
made ah the falling what if I win it no
you won't so shut about about your sad
life I'm a store clerk
oh yeah I guess it works well alright
then go [ __ ] yourself I don't care no no
I'm talking to you know you yeah you I
was talking not you I want some gum no
not you the human I want to buy some gum
okay yes it is I've never worked before
humans don't worry not you the other
forget it
okay I guess you're done now go away
please move over move over right yeah
yeah yeah I'm talking to you bro
who me I the money didn't go through
required to smile and be polite you
don't know how humans work if you think
that's how the real world was you think
we have to oh you sweet summer child oh
it's so cute
whoa no jelly banana I can help you
things you don't even know about le
monkey needs to use the little bathroom
okay there you go
sugar I only have so much sugar oh I
know just the thing for distracting
annoying little girls it's gonna be
super-sized so oh boy there you go
man that technology huh oh are you
greedy little girl what more do you want
here's a Twinkie that's probably a
thousand years old have one with your
diabetes ketchup - oh yeah it's
amazingly expensive surprisingly do you
money give me the money what are you
accusing me of
why is he in charge of your money what
kind of adult parent are you just do
whatever the customer over their
children wants and make sure you always
grab that money I got the money don't
worry about jobbot do you robot even
care about money this place is yeah I
completely agree bro you were gonna
crank this up bro sorry I needed to tone
down the energy just a little bit okay
okay Alan good and then this - okay got
it wait wait there we go you're all good
buddy ring that up what else you would
hell is that
stacking what what is this what is that
cleaning there you go have fun I know
what you got I can make this work
yeah wait how do you understand the
concept of us wiping our own asses and
yet you can't understand the concept of
what's going on in basic human okay
peace out bro have a good one you didn't
pay for it even though I didn't I was
told to always grab the money sounds
like number one lesson boss hello how
you doing I sure do Wow know what the
hell this is but it it's electric blue
goo I love electric blue goo it's got
what plants crave [ __ ] well you know
what no one ever liked electric blue goo
people do like Mountain scream it's got
one plans great [ __ ] why man [ __ ] that
one up okay I always liked sweet generic
off-brand Cola it's going plants crave
oh [ __ ] you didn't want any of this
where am I supposed to get that Oh in
here why don't we need it how about you
get an extra big Dumbo I did shake it
I already shaken I shook tit give me
your money stop talking about me how to
do my job thank you you can't even fool
me you didn't even take one drink you
didn't even open oh I thought he was
gonna explode I mean in a way if that
was stuff blasting out of his anus then
he probably exploded into some degree
before the universal credit system some
humans had more money than they knew
what to do with and struggle to find
ways to spend it how about some of that
how about a little bit of this this this
yes I should probably scan you shouldn't
I give me that back okay you got it I
mean it I'm with it I'm gonna give you
everything you ever wanted
you're gonna be delighted at all the
burritos and [ __ ] and all the grandeur
and all the cool jazz and whatever
they'll this is dapples Brax it's got
what plants crave I didn't even scan it
that one's a freebie all right goodbye I
don't want the change make sure you grab
their money
I wanna end ah what's in here whoo I got
all the cheese I get it you're so funny
pants are falling down
we don't even wear what I unplugged
entertainment is that a porn mag oh it's
not sexy at all I don't know where this
goes what is this hot sauce okay what do
I do with it now supersize it how do I
know in the collar okay bye have a good
one whoever you are you didn't even tell
me that you worked here I'm assuming you
just gave me stuff that was supposed to
be here and you didn't just steal it
from some other store and bring it here
so do hot dogs merch babe at boot
backbeat but don't go back there
literally sugar what do you want them to
do they've got nothing but no III object
to this because these are worth $2 for a
popsicle you frickin thief who's gonna
rob us for $2 good god change to what
why do this why than the make any sense
boss I like this charging it for it
shop no I'm not I didn't even want to do
any of that where are you going but
you're gonna steal something preferably
not something is specially valuable you
know what just to spite you because I
like you less I'm gonna give him the I
don't even know look very deeply into
this tube I guess I didn't bother him
well with customers like this patronage
something happened to him over there
whoa here comes trouble no apparently
not alright shatter it is I already
connected the dots on this joke hey
there you go I'm not gonna try why would
I try I work for okay nevermind then
they went past exclusively in little
value products convenience stores were
often the targets of robbery am I
supposed to feel sad about that okay
anyway next customer I think this box
had a little too much juice attention
yeah too much juice too much 420blaze it
will [ __ ] 420 blaze' juice
you want a burrito I know this because
it says burrito troubles there you go I
got you don't stop getting in the way
you [ __ ] okay I know what you want me
to use my magic machine to make this
magically this dough you half of it
are you saying it's so weird how high
are you from the register just because
your customer isn't bye have a good day
I love you I haven't seen a mess this
big since the human uprising of 2027 oh
they're human I have just the thing what
why don't you try it out the keyhole is
right there by the dial oh I did it
what did main is designed to clean even
the most disgusting you want grab the
controller and clean those stains around
the store oh I'm playing a game within a
game oh man I've made quite a mess
around here all right whatever you're
done good enough supersize that good key
that's a nice key what else come on I'm
ready come on whoa hello
something about this seems a little bit
strange you should probably check their
ID
if it says McLovin I'm gonna be super
pissed adult bought old enough totally
legit xperia x fired never I knew what
that means I think you're good in my
book AB some of that I'm so relieved
have a good day why do these light as
soon as I touch them it doesn't seem
like what it's supposed to be doing oh
okay well the technology is never wrong
okay I guess you can give them their
fireworks you got it too kind of all ran
out but either way I guess okay oh [ __ ]
didn't mean to do that but here you go
[ __ ] damn you get out of here kids get
out here you're lucky it's out that was
strange but the most important thing is
that the product is safe imagine regrow
are you gonna explain that to me boy
alright then well that seems dangerous
no we've captured the suspects we just
need you to point out who did it all
right no matters your chatter let me
make it simple for you here are the
three suspects just hand me the one who
did oh sure you certain
mr. fences nun oh this one this has gold
right here your finance okay bye have a
nice day Bandido you're gonna be fine I
sure am I'm just gonna chug this pink
stuff because it feels good when it
touches my brain okay anyway I'm going
to eat a burrito and then forget all my
troubles in another reality okay so Zach
is the store clerk job simulator there's
only one left to go and I've already
done half of it but I'm gonna blast
through it for you guys from the next
video that we do with this virtual
reality stuff check out all the other
cool stuff even oculus rift stuff that I
played a long time ago there's links in
the description the playlist full of
cool videos that you want to see thanks
again everybody and as always I'll see
you in the next video